a new batch of documents related to the
Epstein case have been released this is
the second Trove and oh boy we got some
juicy stuff in here A bunch of A-list
celebrities were named but of course it
doesn't mean that anything wrong it just
means that Epstein liked to walk around
claiming he was friends with a lot of
celebrities but uh you know maybe we
should take a look you know who these
people are cuz it's been known for a
long time what Epstein was doing but the
big story is that according to one of
the emails in the documents Bill Clinton
went to Vanity Fair and demanded they
not report on what Epstein was doing
with his trafficking if you know what I
mean and so this appears to be an
accusation a report a claim be very
careful here that Bill Clinton was
trying to cover up what Epstein had been
doing questions are why so far it's only
speculation but oh boy we better talk
about that one we got some political
news as well uh the other day there was
WID there was reporting of widespread
bomb threats at numerous state capital
buildings sparking evacuations